>>> THE NEW CNN REPORTING ON THE
JANUARY 6th COMMTEE AND
TOMORROW'SEARING.
IT WILL BE THE LAST PUBLIC
HEARING BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND SOCES TELLING
CNN THE COMMITTEE WILL TREAT
THIS HEARING AS A CLOSING
ARGUMENT MAKING ITS CASE THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD
TRUMP, REMAINS A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
SOURCES ALSO SAY THE HEARING
WILL INCLUDE SOME NEW EVIDENCE
GATHERED SINCE THE LAST
COMMITTEE PUBLIC HEARING BACK IN
JULY.
WITH US TO DISCUSS THIS
REPORTING OUR CNN SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT JAMIE GANGLE, SARA
MURRAY.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE NEW EVIDENCE.
>> RIGHT.
>> NO LIVE TESTIMONY.
IS THAT CONFIRMED?
NO LIVE TESTIMONY BUT INSTEAD
THE WITNESSES THEY'VE GATHERED
SINCE JULY, WHAT DO WE EXPECT?
>> WITH THIS COMMITTEE ANYTHING
CAN HAPPEN.
>> EXCELLENT POINT?
RIGHT NOW NO LIVE WITNESSES, BUT
THERE ARE NEW WITNESSES WE'VE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE WHO HAVE BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THERE IS NEW TESTIMONY FROM OLD
WITNESSES THAT WE HAVE SEEN
BEFORE, THERE IS A LOT OF NEW
EVIDENCE AND I AM TOLD BIG
PICTURE, ALL ROADS LEAD TO
DONALD TRUMP.
AS YOU SAID, THE POINT THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO MAKE IS THAT HE
REMAINS A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER.
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th, BUT
BECAUSE HE CONTINUES TO SAY THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
HE CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ELECTION
DENIERS.
THEY SEE THIS AS A THREAT 2024,
DEMOCRACY IN PERIL.
JUST A COUPLE OF NAMES WE MAY
GET TESTIMONY FROM TOMORROW,
FORMER TRUMP CABINET MEMBERS WHO
HAVE TESTIFIED SINCE THE LAST
HEARING.
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
PO
POMPEO.
ELAINE CHAO WHO RESIGNED THAT
DAY AND STEVE MNUCHIN.
>> POMPEO AND MNUCHIN, THE
TESTIMONY YOU'RE HEARING, THE
DAMNING TESTIMONY YOU'RE HEARING
AND EVEN THROUGH THE BIDEN
INAUGURATION COMES FROM THOSE
LOYAL TO DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS CONGRESSWOMAN ZOLOFT.
THE PHONE STARTS RINGING.
>> THERE'S SOME NEW MATERIAL
THAT, YOU KNOW, I FOUND AS WE
GOT INTO IT PRETTY SURPRISING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING SOME OF
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY FOUND BUT
AUGMENTING WITH NEW MATERIAL
THAT WE DISCOVERED THROUGH OUR
WORK.
THROUGHOUT THIS SUMMER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S INTENTIONS WERE,
WHAT HE KNEW, WHAT HE DID, WHAT
OTHERS DID.
>> ONE OF THE POINTS THAT WE'RE
TOLD THEY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
TOMORROW IS THE SPECIFICITY AND
THE REPETITIVE NATURE OF
WARNINGS TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES THAT THIS
COULD TURN VIOLENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, AS JAMIE POINTED OUT
THEY HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND, FRANKLY, NOW
HAD A COUPLE OF EXTRA WEEKS TO
TINKER WITH THE HEARING TO GET
THEIR POINT ACROSS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT BEFORE WE
WERE HEARING ABOUT HOW LITTLE
INFORMATION THEY COULD GET FROM
THE U.S. SECRET SERVICE.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE ANYMORE.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS IN
THE TROVE OF INFORMATION THEY'VE
RECEIVED BUT THEY HAVE, YOU
KNOW, MORE THAN 800,000 PAYMENTS
OF INFORMATION THEY'VE NOW
OBTAINED FROM THE SECRET SERVICE
AND WOULD EXPECT TO SEE SOME OF
THAT.
WE ARE EXPECTING TO SEE NEW
VIDEO IN THIS BUT AS JAMIE SAID
THE IDEA IS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
AT THE CENTER OF THIS AND STILL
REMAINS THE PRE-EMINENT VOICE IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND A
DANGER TO DEMOCRACY AND FRANKLY
ON THAT DAY I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FEELS LIKE THEY CAN'T
DRIVE HOME THE POINT ENOUGH THAT
HE KNEW WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT
THE CAPITOL, THAT HE KNEW THIS
RIOT HAD STARTED AND DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING TO STOP IT.
>> THE KEY POINT, THE CLOSEST
PARALLEL WE HAVE IS THE 9/11
COMMISSION WHICH TALKED ABOUT
THAT DAY, BUILT UP DOCUMENTARY
EVIDENCE, THE DOTS NOT CONNECTED
BUT THEN PROJECTED FORWARD.
WHAT DOES THE UNITED STATES HAVE
TO DO TO IMPROVE ITS
PREPARATION.
THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS JAMIE
RASKIN, SAYS THIS IS WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO TOO.
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL HOLDING
RALLIES AND SUPPORTING
CANDIDATES AND WANTS TO BE A
CANDIDATE IN 2024.
THERE REMAINS A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER.
THIS IS NOT ANCIENT HISTORY BUT
A CONTINUING THREAT.
THAT IS THE POINT THEY WANT TO
MAKE, THIS IS NOT JUST COMPILING
THE HISTORY OF THAT DAY.
>> AND THEY WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS COMING UP.
I WILL ALSO TELL YOU WE'VE HEARD
IT THROWN AROUND THIS IS THE
LAST HEARING.
I GOT MULTIPLE CALLS LAST NIGHT
SAYING, THIS IS NOT THE LAST
HEARING.
THERE MAY VERY WELL BE SEVERAL
MORE HEARINGS, KEEP IN MIND THE
COMMITTEE STILL HAS TO DECIDE
WHETHER IT'S GOING TO SEND A
LETTER TO DOJ ABOUT A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A HEARING IN DECEMBER TO
ANNOUNCE THEIR REPORT, BUT I WAS
TOLD LAST NIGHT THEY CONTINUE TO
INTERVIEW PEOPLE, MORE EVIDENCE
IS COMING IN, MORE TESTIMONY IS
COMING IN.
IF THEY FIND NEW INFORMATION
THEY'LL BE BACK OUT.
>> THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO JUST
SORT OF JUST STOP AND SIT BACK
AND TRY TO WRITE THEIR REPORT.
YOU KNOW THE MEMBERS ARE SAYING
WE ARE WRITING THIS REPORT AND
WORKING DILIGENTLY ON IT BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE'LL STILL BRING
IN NEW WITNESSES AND TRYING TO
DIG UP MORE INFORMATION UNTIL
THE END.